cos'era questo tour i 9 c è lo zio
bachar lengies live che c'è stata
consigliata da voi come l'ultima
challenge in cui facciamo tre colori di
colla peuterey correre great peter con
il pigmento non mi ricordo quando tempo
fa le altre cose mi è piaciuta
tantissimo quindi ci avete chiesto di
farne un'altra e cioè di mettere tre
mistery box sono un'acqua un'acqua
un'acqua poi ci sono i pigmenti che mi
sono piaciuti tantissimo e poi abbiamo
aggiunto una cosa delle nuove con le
glitterate che ho comprato l'altro
giorno da tiger 16 dei colori diversi
ma perché non c'è il vero è che quando
albergo anche come mai prima magari e
dentro una di queste scatoline quindi
come sempre dovremo bendarsi e pescare
una cosa alla volta
tre turni pescheremo una cosa alla volta
e vedremo come diventando solo slime
trasparente aspetteremo ancora meglio i
colori
provate a dominare nei commenti giacché
colore secondo voi uscirà brio e che
colore sia vitale grossa è il grigionese
è ancora non abbiamo trovato in nove per
i nostri ospiti speciali fa pagare ai
nidi consigliate si prende con i
commenti volete vedere altre sale slime
lasciate un bel laiche consigliateci
pure i commenti che altri challenge fare
quelle più belle viste sarà un pollicino
e andremo a farle siete pronti a
prenderci bloccarne abbiamo dato a
impartire allora iniziò da cosa iniziamo
dalle mistery box nelle sale stessa rom
per le loro prede scatto in inverno
mischia scavo è tanto di noi che
facciamo mora si sono speed avanti e
cota non è che devi toccare perché per
quelle quella rettangolare con qui
aspetta che il rischio di nuovo perché
già allora qui quale scelti quale
scienze l'aia è certo quella preso lei
era la stessa location che poteva allora
va break a che cosa c'è dentro
lo scopriremo dopo perché il mio
ok quindi lo bendare e ternate resiste
in testa
slitta ancora la cosa così dai ben dai
quasi pronta dove stanno fede è ok
che cos'è questo sono non mi convince
non mi sembra cosa buona
vediamo ad aprire il nostro mistery box
ed un giorno allo slide e poi
continuiamo con le scelte pronti tre due
uno così non so non ho ancora avuto la
maledizione del vero allora che bello il
comando per ora com'è possibile questa
fortuna già da avvolgere criticamente la
dop herbert e allora
ora andiamo a mettere colorante
infortunata vivere come vedete fa vedere
questo colore mi piace d'altissimo il
color pesca
vediamo come di vento sembra rosso del
mio team ma in realtà è un po più rosa
più rosa arancione appunto un po color
pesca la pesca è un po rozzo ma va bene
perché tanto il colore del mio team
comunque e mezzo futuro vediamo atto che
cos'hai io dal rumore non sono troppo
gonfia ma anche bicolori ma questo già
so che lì caveranno d'apertura dipende
da come lo attivi tantissime perle
colorate su cui musiche bellissime e
vediamo un po geloso
l'impostazione 1 incollata bellissima
però te non sono stanco ma lei
d'altronde sono bellissimi
[Risate]
e adesso si vedono ancora perché tutto
trasparente quindi va bene così
ma ci fa anche le barrire verbi verde
chiaro e ben curati dovesse bello
bellissimo non becchi qualche colore
strano tipo marrone barone di joe
secondo noi e secondo grado di scendere
tocca prima a me e poi a me oppure
possiamo fare nuovamente carta forbice
strazio di casa normale sasso si sentì e
ben imparato a chi mi sia prima più
possibilità per comprendere più colore
visite alla fine un in meno di vedere
come sono normali io vorrei questo rosa
fucsia perché così ci sta ci sta bene
nel mio color pesca
no problem
infatti tutto stessa è l'ottica aspetta
perché si muove casera questo è proprio
quello che ha sorpreso del rosso e
dorato o sotto il brand con riuscirà di
natale oppure a gennaio uscirà per dire
soltanto possono mettere il bear bologna
che belle che non prendono il verdi ma
che gusto c'è scusa a tutti quanti
possiamo vedere di non vedere a rita che
prender perdere quanto scrive
telecomando ho fatto
[Musica]
presto già fortunato giaquinto dorato
non vedo l'ora di vedere come ci sta con
il mio color pesca giallorosso diventa
allora potevo girare a tutti che fate
ben più agitato da te ne uscirà sapendo
che qui avremo sicuramente lo slime
albero di natale e verde con la pallina
mamma ma dove devo andare a casa in
quello slide marroncino che riuscirà a
guardare ma ronzino ingrid e sia grigia
e trasparente con le sfumature verdi
gang sono i 20 sull'anno prossimo non
sono ritardo dai vediamo il mio derma è
stupito è bello perché trasparente se mi
fai ridere è sempre evidenziatore
evidenzia chi allora chiudere tubolari
diventerà anche il suo vorrebbe essere
uno slide di natale non è mosso contro
quelle cose dorate emergono le ghirlande
più chiesto che colori diventerà questa
formula ora pesca primaria memory
mi ha detto valore che colore diventa
arma girlanda questa cosa dirà fini
proprio tempo e un pesca glitter osa
adesso marrone scaduto la smetti non è
un errore dell'oggetto parte benissimo
che per me ma cos è la fragola il più
bello sarà il mio or sono sicuro vedremo
dipende da che è pigmento peschiamo
davvero quello cambierà attraverso il
terriccio suoi atleti attese il marrone
marrone
[Applauso]
per evitare il terzo e ultimo round
forbice la fascia
l'ultimo round da sempre il più
difficile perché può cambiare
completamente perché ad esempio adesso
inoltre mi piace tantissimo color pesca
con i glitter dorati qualche sottratto
con lui di dirlo cambiate mi piace
tantissimo
guarda che bello sembra che si prova di
un bagnoschiuma alla rampa albero
va bene che scegliamo il filmato
sbagliato potrebbe rovinare tutto
soprattutto il tuo no almeno sembra
bellissimo quale superi che ti esca si
sfoga il quale vuoi che ti dica non solo
forse come sia giallo di penso che il
giallo sia quello che si sta meglio
nessuno
uno di questi due gialli forse questo
più bello john kerry tecnici che
produciamo che ne so forse questa
pedagogia beh non è oro a noi spetta
queste kurt beck perché mi emoziona del
volta perché si sta bene qua riusciva il
grigio da moretti anche il giallo però
spero che non riesca nero grigio scuro
bianco ma bianca e marc janko secondo
menti da un bel della sfumare una bella
cena e una parlata stare bene e lavorati
[Musica]
ma che stai facendo questo mischiato
sentito rumori strani ai fatti poi c'è
insomma sono così vicini tutti vicini
aiutano nei bar pescara
questa è la poca fortuna
ok se ne tornava ultimamente sono molto
fortunata nelle cialente cosa sta
succedendo all'anno nuovo tu sei
fortunata io sono fortunato
allora ben totti lavora non vedo l'ora
di vedere come usciranno hai fatto
aspetta è fatto è fatto
no ho fame anche dai cosa mi posso
mangiare bene
[Musica]
aspetta è così dissimili vede bene che i
do so benissimo quest'anno erano tutti
qua
[Musica]
cosa perché la tua faccia il video è
attirato il marrone perché lei ripetuto
talmente tante volte che la retina come
questo è per il 2019
questo è lo slide di natale 2000 19 dove
abbiamo il colore marrone del tronco del
colore realtà dell'albero di natale e le
palline colorate della giuria dal 15 st
[Applauso]
momenté alzi la mano chi a volte non
capisce cosa dici che io allora ecco qua
il colore che mi è capitato bellissimo
perché il giallo dorato quindi sono
troppo curioso di vedere come diventa
del sito
ma che bella naturalmente vediamo come
diventa
che bello fatto più dorato dorato con
sfumature pesca è troppo bello sembra
arancione franco curioso di vedere con
presidente questo bene con il marrone
premiano tu hai delle decorazione
momento questo è oro e questo è pigmento
due rami e dorato e dura tissima basta
considerare pronto meccaniche guardato
qualche non è bellissimo e d'ora uscirà
dorato con le sfumature verdi
conoscendo un po e verde dorate che è
certo e dorato guarda diciamo
chiaramente diciamo che era meglio
gardone molto invitante anche col andato
a male mi ha nominato da time
un po particolare magari quando la tv ha
fra l'altro detto che era loro non era
malvone vedi che non è marrone oro
verdone tutto tutto il merito è uscito
una sorta di pescara nazione
ora mi avverti il trono frullato buono
mi ha messo un po troppi broccoli totti
troppo limitato un po troppo scuro
scriverebbero manca poco questo è ora
andiamo ad attivarli e vediamo come sono
una volta tv poi potrete votare è il
voto è sempre in base alla spesa di soli
smr potrebbe news la il mis colore è
bellissimo è diventato un arancione
chiaro vedete è un bel po lucido e alle
sfumature gialle del pigmento ora
purtroppo sapete con l'eco la
trasparente si formano un sacco di
bollicine e infatti è pieno di bolle
quindi non si vede proprio bene il
colore originale comunque uscite una
scorta di aggressione chiami piaciuto
come bellissimo possiamo aver mai fatto
un live di questo colore
e ora
i suoni tipo king un po
bellissimo il colore non è stato però un
pochettino così cosa non l'ho tirato
troppo per evitare che si indurisca
guarante prezzi allora che cosa ne
pensate del virus lime che dopo gli date
mandarino tipo e color mandarino la lega
pesca a cessare le dive stato realizzato
e chiaro tipo il mandarino perché allora
esiste un bel ritorno che è crollato un
po alla mammella
da allora il colore mi piace
diciamo che è che nel piano verde
marrone chiaro sabbia non lo attivato
bene per niente però però lato positivo
nessuno delle palline è caduta ancora
avanti si stanno bene le palline
con lo spaccio il porting rimanendo
incastrato con la mano non ha funzionato
tutto bene
in ogni caso colpo libro non è proprio
eccellenza dove alemanno sporchissima ci
sono molti modelli giorno più bello che
hai visto mai
ma che bello è bello solido allungabile
guardate guardate base per l'italia
perché quello più italia bellissima no
dai il tuo questa volta però il mio
carino
certo il colore il tuo 3 un bel colore è
il nome coca cola scusata questa è una
zuppa di verdure dagli spiragli
e patate e morbida comunque nancy che
bello eravamo a questa volta ha
differito per questa volta sembrano dire
no perché le palline del mio no più
belle colorate del tutto molto dorato il
petto dorato e mannarino del verde
durato dell'orsa della e non è male
basta farlo bene a me piace il mio modo
vitale e tutti i volti vitale anche
bravo ma che stai facendo rischiare a
fare le palle con qualcosa che bolle
molle e ottica bello guarda quant'è
bello cioè che gli vuoi dire senza
sembrate ma separati santo seppe
riconoscere mentre team rosso se ha
vinto vitale team tanto elastico è il
tuo è così elastico giustificare per
vedere in azione i media nella sempre
callens i nuovi video